[Musique]
opération séduction pour le gouvernement
en franche comté jean baptiste lemoyne
s'est prêté au jeu
début de la visite au centre
d'exportation de montbéliardes avec pour
mission rassurer les professionnels
notamment sur la question des marchés
iranien vers coopérative reçu un email
du trésor américain le soir même de
l'annnonce de trump par rapport à l'iran
sur les sanctions et c est en fait on a
besoin d'être protégée si vous de cette
décision américaine si elle se traduit
par des sanctions contre les entreprises
européennes ça signifie une forme
d'agression commercial et qu'on ne
serait tolérée on ne fait pas ça un
allié du côté des acteurs de la filière
le message est tout aussi clair les
pouvoirs publics doivent intervenir pour
ouvrir de nouveaux contrats à
l'international
aujourd'hui c'est dur le grand export
parce que il y a de l'asthme des
problèmes logistiques des problèmes
techniques il ya des problèmes culturels
et là effectivement il ya aussi des
problèmes politiques
donc c'est très intéressant que nos
politiques viennent nous voir finalement
nous disant comment autre lieu autre
thématique cette fois la francophonie au
centre de linguistique appliquée
principal objectif de la journée faire
de la pédagogie
comprenez défendre les réformes
entreprises et à venir il faut toujours
expliquer parce que pour faire adhérer à
des changements qui parfois sont
profonds en matière
de fiscalité en matière d'allègement de
charges de droit du travail etc
il faut bien expliquer où on veut aller
et puis que nous puissions partager
cette ambition étonnante par le nombre
de ministres et secrétaires d'état
déployés aux quatre coins de la france
cette action communication halle est
aussi par son caractère immédiat et le
plus grand ensemble